wealth in which case
we're recording everything's good yeah
cool right excellent so um we've been
discussing subjectivity versus
objectivity in many of our shows
recently and dr andrew lampanen is a
senior research scientist at deepmind
and he thinks that symbols are
subjective in the relativistic sense
now dr lampenin completed his phd in
cognitive psychology at stanford
university his background is in
mathematics physics and machine learning
his research interests are in cognitive
flexibility and generalization and how
these abilities are enabled by factors
like language memory and embodiment
andrew with his co-authors have just
released a paper called symbolic
behavior in artificial intelligence now
andrew led in the paper by saying that
the human ability to use symbols has yet
to be replicated in machines
he thinks that one of the key areas to
bridge the gap here is considering how
symbol meaning is established and he
strongly believes that it's the symbol
users themselves who agree upon the
symbol meaning and that the use of
symbols entails behaviors which coalesce
agreements about their meaning which in
plain english means that symbols are
defined by behaviors rather than their
content
now andrew thinks that mathematics for
example is more than just symbolic
manipulation
but there's something extra
something fuzzy how do you get intuition
how do you communicate it to others
could it be partially socially
constructed for example and i don't
think andrew means fuzzy and extra in a
david chalmers kind of hard problem of
uh consciousness notion he's referring
more to its complexity and relativistic
nature now i already know at this point
that my co-interviewer
dr duggar is foaming at the mouth he's
chomping on the bit that these forbidden
utterances have been spoken that they've
left my lips but it should at least make
for a very interesting and lively
discussion now andrew tweeted back in
march that arguments saying that humans
do x and this particular model doesn't
do y a flawed because the model might
simply lack the right experience or the
right knowledge assessment it might be
brittle anyway andrew it's an absolute
pleasure welcome to mlst
thank you so much for having me i didn't
realize my whole twitter record was
going to get reviewed here so i
might have to be careful i say on
twitter in the future hey that's good
that's gonna be nice for anyone at any
time right
very true everyone has to read that book
by john ronson uh you've been shamed you
know talking about the perils of justine
sacco
uh hashtag has justine landed yet but um
anyway just to frame this up a little
bit um in your paper you invoke the
so-called triadic relationship of
meaning with symbols right which means
that you think that symbols are entities
that mean something to someone and this
relativistic interpretation of symbols
is in the philosophical motif or
tradition of wittgenstein so
wittgenstein said that we should
understand words not by
the kind of content of the words if you
like but indeed how the words are used
and this should be familiar to um you
know folks that do machine learning it's
a very similar idea to recommendation or
collaborative filtering where we should
infer what the meaning of a piece of
content is by its affinity to others or
how it's kind of you know engaged with
by others rather than the actual content
of the thing um so we see this idea all
over the place i think the page rank
algorithm is another example but um if
you don't mind andrew could you and
first of all i think let's make this as
pedagogical as possible so explain
everything like we're five can you give
us the elevator pitch for your symbolism
paper
yeah so i think the
the basic question we were trying to ask
is
what
are the you know what is necessary for
getting the kinds of intelligent
behavior that humans exhibit i think
that's what we all agree regardless of
what you know computational principles
we think need to implement it
a starting point for getting general
intelligence is getting to the level of
intelligence that humans exhibit
and so
what we were trying to do in the paper
was
examine some of the assumptions that
have been made in the past about what
that intelligence looks like and
maybe try to critique them or
re-understand them in terms of more
in terms of broader observations about
what humans are and are not capable of
doing and then think about the
the kinds of computations and the kinds
of ideas that might underlie
you know systems that could be
intelligent in the way that humans are
so the paper isn't laid out quite like
that we start off as you say by
articulating this sort of triadic
definition of symbols that goes back to
a long philosophical tradition um
including pearson vickenstein as you say
um
but our general motivation i think
starts from the behavior and that's what
you see in the title of the paper
so
i think the
the
explaining like i'm five argument is
if you look at what humans do
and what classical symbol systems do
they're not very similar
humans exhibit all sorts of ways in
which we're biased by the meaning of
what we're reasoning about for instance
in ways that a symbol system that
totally dissociates reasoning from the
underlying semantics would not
um
and we think that's not a flaw of human
reasoning but it's actually the reason
that we're able to reason so effectively
in domains where
classical systems just it's completely
infeasible for them to work and that's
the reason for instance that
mathematicians are able to have much
clearer ideas and reason much more
effectively than even a carefully
developed symbol system that's designed
for mathematical
computation
uh so for for example something like
mathematica
um
so
our argument in the paper then is if we
want to have intelligence that's more
like this kind of human intelligence
that can go beyond
classical symbol systems that can reason
in the domains where they're sort of
infeasible to use
then we might want to take a more
human-like perspective on how our
systems should learn so our system
should learn
from the kinds of experiences that
humans have
which
especially
an especially important part of that
experience is
sort of social interactions with someone
else we have to coordinate on meaning so
there's a number of psychologists and
neuroscientists who have suggested that
this process of coordinating on meeting
with others is an important part of our
cognitive development that leads us to
the ability to for instance form
generalizable abstractions or even to
leads us to the ability to form symbols
so so that was sort of part of our
inspiration for making this argument
interesting and this is one reason why i
think both tim and i so much enjoy
talking to uh the authors because one
one can read a paper in in my case say i
read the paper but i missed for some
reason or another a really critical
point which you
which you just raised which is
you're saying essentially what you're
saying is that the the syntactic
manipulation if you will the symbols
is certainly an important piece of what
you can do with symbols so you're not
you're not downplaying the importance of
manipulation as far as i can as i can
tell but what you're saying is that
the semantic mappings
are just just as important and on one
hand of course it's obvious it's like
yeah we you know of course symbols have
a semantic mapping otherwise what are we
even doing with them because they're not
even icons or not even indexes they're
just these these you know things they
have to be linked to some kind of
meaning but
more importantly the fact that human
beings
understand
the semantic mapping
gives them additional power beyond just
syntactic manipulation if i heard you
correctly
but i want to say something a little
more fundamental here which is that the
syntax is not important in itself the
syntax doesn't matter it's only useful
in so far as it tells you in the end
something about the semantics right the
only reason that people care about the
fact that for instance you can apply
certain logical operators and get
something that's consistent with them is
because it tells you something about the
semantics of what those propositions
mean oh sure well i agree with that but
on the other hand what i'm saying is
that syntactic manipulation is extremely
powerful
i mean you know our ability to abstract
and create
manipulations operators whatever you
want to call them that can even
correspond at all to
to
semantic preservation if you will or
maintaining semantically useful
properties i think that's that's really
at the heart of the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics you know if
you will
yeah i think that's a great point but
it's it all comes down to that semantics
and agreeing on what those syntactic
operations and operators actually mean
right and i think that's the distinction
that we're highlighting here and i think
that's the reason that humans are able
to
use these tools that's what syntactic
operations are right they're tools that
humans have developed and we've sort of
agreed on systems for using them that
allow us to do powerful things with them
but
i so i think that syntactic operations
are useful as tools you know my
background is in mathematics
certainly used a lot of logic in my time
and i use you know symbolic programming
languages every day but i don't think
that that's
i don't think that those systems are
part of intelligence and that's the
important distinction right they're
useful tools for intelligent systems to
use to accomplish our goals which in the
end are about the semantics that's a lot
like what uh you know richard feynman
probably would have said something
similar because he was he was always
pointing out look these are just these
tools you know they they may seem magic
but we just follow the rules and we get
useful
semantic results essentially
certainly yeah um
and i think it takes
an intuition like feynman's which is
something he was known for to be able to
use the rules effectively in order to
find something really new in many cases
right that's why you know being an
insightful mathematician or physicist
takes a lot that goes beyond the ability
to just make logically correct
inferences that's part of why
mathematics and physics are so hard
and that i think is the part that has
been under emphasized in
classical approaches to symbol
manipulation
it's like well what is the part that
tells you
which inferences are the right ones to
think about
and tells you you know what is the
meaning of the inferences you're making
yeah and in fact maybe i can i can put
this uh for for my fellow folks that are
obsessed with
kind of let's say computational
complexity i mean
sure you could write a program that
could explore every every possible let's
say application of of logical operators
to some set of axioms or whatever but
that's this this vast space this
combinatorially large
impossible to explore by brute force
space and and what i'm what i'm taking
from what you're saying is that
this human semantic intuition acts as
this kind of heuristic almost to
to focus down within that vast space on
the things that that matter and end up
being
useful is that fair
that is certainly a part of what we're
saying so we we quote several
mathematicians in the paper who are sort
of explicitly addressing this argument
by some of the classical symbol uh
system advocates that
syntactic manipulations are all that
matter the mathematicians say things
like well it's actually the ideas behind
the manipulations that tell you which
sort of things are important so that's
that's exactly what you're saying about
narrowing down the search space figuring
out what the right things to do are but
i think there's something more even more
fundamental than that here which is that
humans are able to reason about our own
reasoning processes for example to
develop these kinds of symbolic
manipulation processes these syntactic
manipulation processes
and i think that
having that ability
is important as well and is something
that
is difficult to achieve if you stick to
strictly syntactic manipulations right
you're sort of assuming the manipulation
process that you're going to be using to
reason whereas by taking a sort of
meaning first perspective you open the
possibility of
changing those very reasoning processes
and i suspect that this will be
important in developing systems that go
beyond human intelligence and quite
possibly even in achieving human-like
intelligence
yeah i'm finding this really fascinating
and we've touched on so many of these
ideas when we speak with cognitive
scientists and i really can be convinced
that there's a lot to be said to me it
reminds me a lot of discussions we've
had with um people who study cybernetics
and you know concepts like embodiment
and autopiosis and thinking of
intelligence as being a process thinking
of it being externalized quite often we
talk about subjectivity and creativity
and quite often with the the word that
we get to very quickly is the word
subjectivity and in a word subjectivity
is a suitcase word i don't like that
word uh because i i try to unpack what
you mean by subjectivity because you are
actually talking about this quite
complex open-ended process so um yeah
when we've been speaking about
subjectivity recently um in respect of
um symbol use or certainly when you've
been using the word i think you're using
it as a synonym for relativistic and
complex right which is to say that it's
it's not so much the subjective
you know it could be objective if you
like it's just so complex that we're
deciding to use the word subjective um
and you know when you say it's complex i
think you also mean it's entangled with
the state of the interpreters to a
certain extent would you agree with that
interpretation i i certainly agree with
the latter part the idea that's
entangled with the state of the
interpreters i'm not
sure to what extent i agree that it
could be objective i mean
i think that
almost anything is
subjective in fact if you take for
example you could think about the
distinction between like newtonian and
hamiltonian classical mechanics for
example either of those is a valid
formulation of classical mechanics and
it's sort of subjective which
perspective you take what's the right
way you want to describe the system
right so i think that there's
even in these
seemingly
objective frameworks there's a lot of
subjectivity in the way we're actually
choosing to set up the very system we're
reasoning over
and
so i think that it's hard for me to say
that there is anything that is
definitely objective
except for again the semantics that's
out there in the world but that's a very
specific thing a lot of the things we
talk about in the world are our
abstractions which again are
subjectively applied on top of that
well this is this is a point that that i
often make when when i'm kind of
let's say debating with our friends
which is for example
in my view and i think this is pretty
well established you know all
probabilities are conditional
there's absolutely no such thing
whatsoever as an objective probability
it's like anybody who ever writes down
p of a that's really just short a
shortcut for p of a given k it's like
some stuff you assumed some prior
knowledge and if you forget that if you
forget that there's always this
conditionality you get into all all
sorts of trouble i mean is that a fair
analogy here definitely yeah and it's
it's like arguments that have been made
about the scientific process too that
we're always working within a certain
paradigm and everything that we study is
with respect to that paradigm right and
so whoa yeah
and you're kind of pointing at something
potentially very deep here that i want
to explore and let me just set this up
by making
a comment about sir arthur eddington who
is who actually he's the one who got me
started off on
philosophy because i read his book
the philosophy of physical science and
in there he makes this point which is
like look
um science is essentially you're like a
fisherman say you have a net that has
you know two centimeter by two
centimeter you know holes you're
obviously not going to catch any fish
that are only one centimeter big and so
you may conclude the ocean only contains
you know fish larger than uh you know
two centimeters etc
that's the nature of subjectivity in the
sense that your tools that you're using
are always filtering out you know part
of the universe you're kind of missing
things
and you said something really
interesting to me a few minutes ago
which is that there's this deeper more
fundamental kind of reasoning i'll just
call it for now that human beings do in
this semantic space
and through that we're able to create
symbolic systems
that represent you know
aspects of that or parts of that and we
can create all kinds of math to you know
to do things
my question is and because eddington
made this comment he's like we may never
be able to get out of this
this notion of subjectivity we're always
going to be limited in this way and
you're making this point that like we
have this deeper more fundamental
semantic reasoning which we can even
reason about and create symbolic systems
but they only capture a part of it are
we forever stuck that way like is anyone
ever going to be able to create
a symbolic system that actually
completely captures
the semantic reasoning that we do
that's a very
interesting question i'd like to
think
that it's possible to create a system
that captures it yes
i think that
so when you say create a symbolic system
i think it's important to be
clear about what you mean by symbolic
there like are you taking a perspective
on symbols like we are sort of like
symbols are subjective and so one part
of that symbol system would be the
interpretation or are you taking more of
uh you know physical symbol system
hypothesis perspective um
that distinction seems important to me
regarding how i'm going to answer this
question
okay so i
maybe maybe i'll ask both at the same
time which is
can we create an abstract symbolic
system that can be separated from any
physical implementation you know that's
a substrate independent that captures
this semantic reasoning
or can we only ever create or is it
possible and or can we create a symbolic
system that's connected to some type of
physical embodiment that captures this
this semantic reasoning
i'm
fairly confident that we can create one
that's connected to physical embodiment
i'm less confident about the abstract
case
but i don't want to completely rule it
out
especially because
you know
if you think
that humans are
some sort of
symbol-using system
and you think that you're a physicalist
you think that you could eventually
simulate a human with a physics
simulator then you probably think that
you know at some point this all grounds
out or you know if you think that neural
networks can do any sort of interesting
reasoning neural networks are really
implemented in a classical symbol system
in a programming language right they're
just a set of rules about what you do
with numbers and how to combine them to
get other numbers out um then you have
to think that in some sense yes
you can implement
intelligence in a
in an abstract symbol system
but that might not
be
the
right
language to describe the intelligence in
an interesting way
in the same sense that
you know for instance uh
you can
describe a an ideal gas as by looking at
this the small interactions of the
particles but it's much easier and
perhaps more informative to describe it
at a macro level in an
entirely different framework
and so
i think that's the distinction i would
like to draw there it's
if you think that you know intelligent
systems can be simulated in computers
which
most people probably agree on
then
in some sense yes it's implementable in
a purely abstract symbol system but that
might not be the right language to
describe what's really going on
it's quite funny we seem to be talking
about strong emergence on every single
show lately but um
i wanted to um to talk a little bit
about our friend dr walid suburb because
he he is a go-fi person and he's a
universalist
and i want to understand how your
thinking differs from his because i i
actually think maybe you don't disagree
so um
yeah he thinks that we have these
so-called universal cognitive templates
um he thinks it's one of the most
important ideas in cognitive cognitive
psychology he's a huge fan of our friend
jerry fodor he thinks that language is a
system of thought and has primacy for
intelligence i know you don't andrew and
you know of course it's an open question
how much thinking should reside just in
the uh in the language modality but back
to wally he often refers to some of
these templates he gives the example of
modus ponens or the most like primitive
syllogism which is to say like if p then
q p therefore q like a simple example of
this is um if today is tuesday then john
will go to work today is tuesday
therefore john will go to work and he
also cites the transitive relation
example so a implies b b implies c
therefore a implies c so
walid would argue that these universal
cognitive templates correspond to
physical reality they are not invented
under any circumstances he really turns
his nose up at that idea and i have a
feeling that you wouldn't disagree with
him right i mean for example even walid
acknowledges that the interpretation or
the meaning of a symbol can be
subjective uh you know for example you
can interpret the meaning of a painting
uh this is in in stark contrast with the
symbolic notion of of implication or
transitivity i mean i have slightly
relativistic tendencies myself by the
way not i would tell walid that i mean i
i could be convinced that language is an
emergent or partially emergent
phenomenon and i do believe that these
universal cognitive templates exist
and would exist if the universe didn't
exist so i can't quite um reconcile
these two ideas but i don't think they
necessarily are contradictory do you
i
yeah it's an interesting question i
think
the way that i prefer to think about it
is that these si tools like syllogisms
are useful
descriptions useful abstractions one can
form from the world they describe
patterns that we observe
patterns of inferences that are valid to
make for instance and
that's much like the way that something
like newtonian mechanics describes
patterns that are valid in the world
under certain regimes
but i wouldn't say that newtonian
mechanics is a fundamental
part of the world really certainly in
that case it seems to be more an
abstraction that's useful for describing
certain regimes of a more complicated
system right um and so i think i don't
have a strong philosophical commitment
at the moment on where the
rules of logic and syllogisms fall
in part because
it's not
clear to me that we even have a
i don't know if there's an objective
definition of truth that everyone can
agree on right so to have a notion of
logic you need to agree on what's true
and philosophers actually have a little
bit of trouble with even this issue
right so i think that
it's it's tricky to say and it's at
least
practically easier to take the stance
that look these are valid things that we
can say that help us to improve our
inferences we can make in the world and
to help us to make predictions about
what things will and won't happen and
that is a
stance you can take without needing to
make any philosophical assumption about
whether they are themselves an inherent
part of the world or just something
that's useful to have
well i wonder if if uh and i haven't
talked to wally about this so i'm really
speculating here i want to make that i
want to make that clear but i think
part of the
part of the reason to think about that
concern
may may come into play really with
deciding what needs to be encoded is
prior knowledge into
into learning systems because
in other words if there are some things
that really can't be statistically
learned and and i think wally makes the
point that look for example if modus
ponens or whatever other
template you consider as being either
universal or near universal or certainly
one that you wouldn't want to fail to
learn you know uh that that if you're
trying to get it at it by learning
um then you always run the risk of
either not learning it at all or
learning it incorrectly or thinking that
it's statistical when in fact it's you
know much more reliable than that and so
if you don't go ahead and and precede
a uh an artificial intelligence with
some of this these basic universal
templates that we think are pretty darn
reliable that we're just going to be
wasting a lot of parameter space and
data you know on on trying to learn
those things and we might end up not
learning them or learning them you know
incorrectly i think is maybe the concern
there
yeah so i think that's definitely an
interesting argument and of course it
isn't one that's totally resolved or we
wouldn't be talking about it there's two
points i'd like to make the first is
syllogisms are a great case because if
you look at
human syllogistic reasoning
it's actually pretty terrible so your
average human off the street you give
them a syllogism and their assessment of
whether it leads to
this is a classic study from like the
70s their assessment of whether a
syllogism forms a valid argument
including the conclusion is hugely
biased by whether the conclusion fits
within their existing belief structure
so
these cognitive psychologists gave these
arguments syllogistic arguments with
conclusions that were like all people
who are
scientists are educated versus all
people who are educated are scientists
where so you sort of have like a mere
version of the
proposition where one version is
somewhat plausible to people and the
other version seems pretty unlikely
right um and what they found was that
you can you know just take the logical
argument that would lead to this
conclusion you can just flip the terms
around so that you get either of these
conclusions and people's assessment of
the validity of that argument is hugely
affected by the those conclusions and
you can see these sorts of like
patterns of the content affecting
reasoning and all sorts of logical tasks
too like the wasteland selection task
which is a slightly different logic
reasoning task i mean
there's debate about how you should
interpret these things of course and a
lot may depend on who the particular
people are what their educational
backgrounds are and what the um
what the precise instructions they're
given are but i think that
it's interesting to ask well
if you think syllogisms are so
fundamental that they have to be encoded
into intelligence what predictions would
you make about human syllogistic
reasoning
well andrew are you suggesting that
humans are not entirely rational actors
i i think i am yeah
well well we'll look i i just want to
join them for a sec because a lot of
this um
and i know i say this often but a lot of
times people are just insufficiently
darwinian when they analyze these
situations because you have to remember
the human individual
is embedded in a context of life in
general and evolution of the species and
the gene pool and et cetera so the fact
that individual people have encoded or
programmed into them pre-programmed
really these kind of uh errors and you
know things like that
doesn't mean that the overall process
itself isn't isn't conducting a very
rational
you know exploration if you will so i
think we shouldn't read too much into
things like that it's like for example
simple example ants
okay you know ants go and follow
pheromone trails that are left down by
by other ants okay but they also
occasionally fail to do that they have
errors they go off in some
random direction but that's actually
essential for the algorithm to discover
new resources if you're always just
following the path that's been laid down
by others you're not going to explore
right it's like this exploration versus
exploitation trade-off and a lot of the
same type of you know analysis applies
to some of these things like oh my god
people aren't perfectly syllogistic you
know well there's reasons for that right
a lot of reasons for that so let's just
keep that in mind before we uh
bash you know individual human
rationality too much
so i think that's a great point and it
actually leads into the second point i
wanted to make from this which is that
often what i see when you attempt to
build in something like syllogistic
reasoning is that you limit the things
that your system can consider too
strongly and my contention is that that
is why you see that
classical symbol systems say work really
well when you have a perfectly
symbolically structured domain that's
small enough that you can run reasonable
inferences and don't scale to solving
any sort of real world problems that's a
slight exaggeration but at least don't
scale to that without a human having to
come there with our knowledge of the
meanings with our ability as you're
agreeing with me to go beyond that kind
of strict logical reasoning
and to use something else
to reason and so that's why i think that
trying to build
these sorts of structures into our
intelligence is the wrong approach
instead we should teach our intelligence
to use these processes to reason in the
same way that humans can learn how to
use logical reasoning can learn how to
use mathematics to achieve our goals but
it's not a fundamental part of our
intelligence it's a tool that we
constructed together and that we can
also
share with our artificial intelligences
and continue to construct together that
would be my argument
this is such a difficult one i feel like
this is one of the the key fillers of
question philosophical questions that we
need to get over because as you say as
soon as you do come up with a model
you're excluding a lot of richness from
the analysis you're kind of chopping off
many aspects of of the system and a lot
of it comes down to primacy like in the
case of walid is is language the the
primacy to intelligence and maybe we
should have the complete opposite view
um but it just it plays with my
intuitions andrew because i really think
that mathematics is discovered i don't
think it's invented whereas with
language my intuitions aren't quite as
strong as they are with with mathematics
and also you know like um nativists like
chomsky they think that we have a lot of
this apparatus built in also part of my
mind is saying to me you would say that
wouldn't you you know coming from deep
mind you know with huge investments in
the connectionist way of thinking um it
doesn't surprise me that that you would
that you would make that argument and
it also this this whole thing about
maybe both things could be true i
genuinely think that universal cognitive
templates exist and i don't think it's a
dichotomy between these things existing
and having strong emergent phenomena in
the universe
yeah um
yeah i i think that
you're right it's probably not a
dichotomy uh let me
say something about language i guess
since that's come out up a lot and it's
actually a
an interest of mine more
generally
i think that
language plays a very important role in
human cognition undoubtedly
and i think that it's something that's
very important for artificial
intelligence researchers to consider
because i think it gives us ways of
you know it's sort of a
pathway in to creating abstractions
right that's what language really
allows us to do is it allows us to take
a bunch of different things and link
them all together with a single
label and that's a starting point i
think for
building some of the symbolic tools that
we have so i think it's very important
that
again
doesn't rule out the possibility that
it's uh not a fundamental
you know built-in part of our cognition
but it's
culturally constructed and
i think it's a bit messy with
things like language like clearly in
some sense
language is built into humans by
evolution in the sense that like our
voice box and the you know our throat is
adapted to speaking in a way that the
throats of monkeys are close closely
related primates isn't right so clearly
there is some evolutionary
adaptation to
using language i wouldn't deny that
but does any of that
does the
mental part of that adaptation
correspond to something like merge which
i guess is chomsky's most recent
version of this last time i checked um
or some sort of basic recursion
principle or something
that i'm less sure about and again
if you look at how well people do with
something like very deeply nested
recursive causes it's you know maybe not
as well as i would hope from a system
that had recursion built in interesting
but yeah this dichotomy is invention
versus discovery though isn't it and and
usually when people say um invention
what they actually mean is emergence and
we we spoke to david chalmers yesterday
actually and he said that well he
lamented that emergence as the most
abused term in science and we got into
quite an interesting discussion but but
this this this is so fundamental though
because we're trying to run a podcast
here on ai and it just seems like an
infinite regress we're going back to
philosophical um principles and i loved
your conversation on the generally
intelligent podcast by the way folks you
should go and subscribe to that it's
probably the only other podcast similar
to our one but um you know you are
saying that there there's a variety of
of causal mechanisms between language
the world and cognition
and all of these cognitive psychologists
they can't actually agree on on
where to draw the arrows on that diagram
so is does language have primacy does
the world have primacy um
how do we even start when we don't know
something as fundamental as that
yeah i mean
it's a tough question i think this is an
old
problem in science where you want to
reason about a long-term process like
evolution it's not like you can go and
run the experiment and be like well
let's causally manipulate language in
the history of human evolution and then
see what happens right um and so i don't
i don't have an answer for you on that
honestly i don't know where to start
maybe the right place to go is just to
have different people take different
perspectives on this see what they
develop and then see where we end up i
mean i think that's kind of what we're
doing anyway but it might be the best we
can do under the circumstances well it
is it is kind of what we're doing but
but there's this effect of um of the
hardware lottery and things like that
right which is once resources get
invested in a certain direction
then of course more flow there and and
so while we may eventually get to uh
where we want to go
that can actually slow down the process
as well by folking focusing too much
resources down a path and this gets to
what i want to ask you which is whenever
i get excited about some set of ideas
like say what we've been talking about
then then i then i start thinking great
i want to go build that okay so now i
want to go build something that that
embodies you know andrew's ideas and and
really kind of pushes them forward well
i asked you earlier about this kind of
is it possible to create an abstracted
symbolic system that can capture this or
not because it actually has
an important you know effect on the
choice you're going to make here it's
like if you believe it's possible to
create a substrate independent you know
representation of say this deeper
semantic reasoning
well then you can go do it now on on
today's existing computational platforms
and and that sort of thing
you know potentially you can write some
code that can do it if on the other hand
that's maybe not quite as likely that it
there could be some type of substrate
dependence it might get you off thinking
maybe i need an analog you know computer
maybe i need to go start trying to build
ships or use the newer you know analog
chips and play around with them more i
mean do you have an opinion on there
suppose you were you were today you know
there's some research out researcher out
there that says
love your ideas
i want to start working on them right
now would you direct them down the
current hardware lottery path of just
yeah go write some you know code and pie
torch or whatever and off you go or
would you direct them down towards you
know some more um i don't know
speculative or less common less road
less taken like analog computing or
something
wow that's a that's a very
interesting
question i mean i i think
part of my point with saying that you
know in principle it would be
implementable on a
discrete abstract symbolic system if you
could simulate a human or whatever is to
say that yeah might be possible but you
might need an insane amount of
let's say processing power and memory
and so on in order to do so and that
wouldn't be the practical way to do it
in the same way that you know
for instance if you take something like
the difference between classical and
quantum computers and prime
factorization you know yeah it's it's
possible for them both to do this
computation but in one case it's just
you know not feasible with our current
standards in one case it might be
feasible with a
relatively small amount of technology um
technological development
so i think like i'm currently
betting on
something that's built within
computers to be computers that we have
now to be able to achieve something
more like human intelligence
not saying that we're there yet
but
i think that it's important that people
keep working on these alternative
approaches keep developing things like
analog computing neuromorphic computing
spiking networks all the all the things
that people are considering that are
that don't fit nicely necessarily within
the classical computer science paradigm
because yeah i don't i certainly don't
have the answers about what is
you know what is the right way to think
about these things and
sometimes we don't really know the right
way until we see it in retrospect
okay
and
if you are betting suppose you're
somebody who decides to continue betting
on the the current computational
paradigms let's say
um i think i re or i think i glean from
your paper perhaps
you might advocate the need for um
more
open systems where modules are kind of
interacting and developing the
capabilities to create these constructed
you know symbolic
uh systems if you will does does that
lean us towards something like opencog
like ben gertzel's kind of idea that you
need to have a almost an ecosystem where
where uh
where um ais kind of or potential ais
let's say nascent ais can kind of
compete with each other for resources
and that that they survive and they
become useful to one another and that
that's actually like an important
overlay to have on top of a
computational system to have it grow if
you will or evolve you know general
intelligence
it's going to be important to think
about the training paradigms definitely
i'm not sure how i feel about that one
particular so one of the things that we
tried to advocate for in the symbolic
behavior paper and this may be less true
in the more recent version of the paper
than the earlier one which had like
three times as many words in it and was
correspondingly much harder to read
instead of having a bunch of ais that
are interacting with each other
it's going to be more useful and
better for our ultimate goals to have
them interacting with humans or at least
in some ways embedded in human culture
right for several reasons so one thing
is i think that whatever your
perspective is on these fundamental
philosophical issues you can agree that
humans have culturally developed a bunch
of things that are useful tools that we
would want our agents to know about and
the second point is that if we have
artificial intelligence we're going to
want to be able to interact with it as
humans to get it to do things right
we're going to why do we want to have
artificial intelligence well so we can
ask it to help us out with things in the
world
and so we want our artificial
intelligence to be
human compatible in that way and i
suspect that if you were to you know if
you were able to go off and run an
evolution process in some completely
separate world i'm not sure you would
get something that's particularly human
compatible i think having that immersion
in human culture is going to be
important for achieving that i suspect
otherwise i guess it's kind of like
you'll get a you'll get a ai version of
lord of the flies like it's off on this
little island there developing something
that you really wouldn't want to be a
part of
exactly yeah and i think that yeah
particularly this competitive sort of uh
yeah a competitive cost function can
lend itself to developing very
nasty behaviors that you wouldn't
necessarily want to have your ai
learning
social behavior is somewhat common among
animals but it's not that common and
there's a lot of really nasty behavior
out there
i'm really intrigued by something you
said because you know our culture it's a
bit like a computer program and you
could say it it's emerged
and um it's complex isn't it and it's
distributed and it might be you might
say it's undecidable and it's it's also
hard to recreate it because uh you know
when we were talking about the the
various um arguments from simulation uh
or even if we had a conversation with
wolfram for example there's always this
notion of well how do i recreate the
thing that we've already got you know
without starting again from scratch
right because of the irreducibility
argument and so on so i've i'm really
interested by what you're saying because
if we do want to have ai which is
explainable and aligned to our culture
then
what do we do so do do we do we make
them interact in in some in in some kind
of objective way could can you give give
us your thought process yeah so
i don't think this is a solved problem
either but
one
sort of research program that we point
to in the paper not coincidentally
because many of the authors are involved
in that is this sort of
paradigm that's laid out in this
paper on imitating interactive
intelligence at deepmind where basically
we have
recorded a large data set of human human
interactions in a simulated environment
that are involving language so one human
is instructing another human to do
something
in the world
and
one thing you can think about at least
is using that as a starting place for
learning using that as a part of the
learning process trying to
get a system that sort of
in some sense is shaped by that human
human interaction and ultimately
even it would be nice to have a system
that's shaped by system human
interactions once it's developed a
little bit more um
with the efficiency of the
systems we have now i think that would
be a bit slower to develop an ai from
scratch like that but you could imagine
starting from a data set of human human
interactions moving to having human
online interaction for instance that's
one of the points we make in the paper
yeah i guess
you're gonna have a lot of people
worrying out there because uh we've
already seen what's happened when uh we
try to even just train ais on on the
totality of
of human human interaction you know it
goes out there and it finds 4chan and
every other dark corner of the web and
kind of learns
you know some of our worst our worst
traits as well and and i myself at one
time did a lot of online gaming and you
know saw quite a bit of uh
you know behaviors that we wouldn't want
to replicate you know and ai so
it's it's it's an interesting quandary
like how do you
you know how do you train an ai that's
both compatible with human behavior and
learns from human behavior and yet that
at least i would hope can in some ways
be better or uh you know more positive a
more positive influence
on on the world than just yet more
more people or more or more versions of
people that even learn some of the worst
things about what what people do
yeah it's a it's a very interesting
question we're now starting to get into
like plato socrates stuff about what is
virtue and cannot be taught and so on
but uh
i think
i i don't have the full answer i mean
the data set
that i'm talking about has the advantage
that it was not just scraped off the
internet it was relatively carefully
collected from people who were
intentionally trying to create data for
this purpose and so in that sense it
hopefully doesn't have the worst of
4chan at least but it still might not be
the perfect thing and of course
it is
at some level it's going to be important
for a system to understand all aspects
of human behavior i think in order to be
to be better right
and to be able to handle all the
situations that it finds itself in in
the world
and
from that perspective i think we need to
think carefully about well how would you
expose a an agent to
i mean
a problem that we kind of solve with
children
as well like how do you expose
something to all the horrible stuff
that's out there in the world in such a
way that
hopefully it
makes the world a better place i think
that's a
that is a problem that we're going to
have to think a lot about but i do think
again having humans in the loop there
will be very important in helping to
you know shape what behaviors are
considered acceptable
then you have to get into all these
questions of well acceptable to whom and
who sets the standards and so on
that's great yeah lots of 30 issues here
with without going too far um down the
ethics discussion
um do you think that because i like to
think of the
the bad parts of human behavior being a
bit like a storm you know like the storm
on jupiter and i just wondered whether
you thought that we needed to have some
of those storms in order to
um you know bring out some of the other
aspects of human behavior and and i
guess an extension question is when we
spoke to david chalmers we asked him the
question what makes an interesting
simulation you know like is it the
universe mostly filled with gas clouds
or as it is now with just a tiny sliver
of intelligence you know just dotted in
the universe and who are we to say
what's good and and what's better do you
know what i mean what's your take yeah
those are
that's a very
interesting
question i mean i think that we're all
sort of
fumbling along in this i guess and so
yes i think that our
intelligence is
quite
limited in a lot of ways and may
not be
like you're saying at the end may not be
the we certainly don't know all there is
to know about being ethical and so on
and every 50 years or so we've kind of
improved refined our conceptions of this
i would say
at least recently um
so
i think that
this is actually
a point that we
tried to make in the earlier paper that
probably got cut from the shorter
version but
i think that it's important
for
our
artificial intelligence systems to be
able to
develop
a framework of ethics and more generally
frameworks of knowledge that have a kind
of
epistemic humility in the sense that
they accept the possibility that the
very foundations that they're building
on might be a little bit shaky and
should be subject to possibly being
reconsidered at some point in the same
way that we've really fundamentally
rethought some of our ethical
foundations at various times over recent
history
and so
i actually think that this is
a place where
one has to be very careful if one
develops
like let's say a strict rule-based
system for reasoning
you want to make that system amenable
to
change and
possibly to developing
better systems for re for you know
better ethical systems let's say while
at the same time keeping it human
aligned and i think that's a very
challenging
problem but i'm
i'm concerned that
too strict a rule-based
definition of ethics might lead us into
a quagmire where our systems just
fundamentally
are not keeping up with the way that our
notions of ethics evolve
you know ai ethics is a huge
huge kind of thing right now and and
this is maybe even
perhaps a simpler aspect of what we've
been talking about which is okay look
let's forget about trying to figure out
the next generation of of ais you know
just with the current ais that we have
you know some neural network trained to
diagnose
diseases or whatever you know is it fair
is it ethical
and and people are embarked on the very
process at least half of them or more
are embarked on the very process which
maybe you're slightly warning about
there which is they're trying to find
rules you know to determine whether or
not these ais are fair or quantitative
measures of of you know how ethical they
are i mean is is this just a
flawed path for us to be going down i
definitely don't want to say it's a
thought path i mean i think it's very
important to quantitatively assess these
things
i think that where you get into
dangerous
territory is if you think that the end
point is going to be well i slap a rule
on top of the system that makes it fair
let's say
that's where you might start to run into
challenges as our notion of fairness
evolves for instance or if we want our
systems to be able to
develop notions of fairness or to help
us with that development right to help
us figure out what is ethically right
um right so it's it's almost like the
way humans have solved this problem is
we have judges you know we recognize
that you need to have some baseline
rules in place
but they're never going to exactly
demarcate
the boundary there's a degree of
vagueness there and so we have to have
agents that they can look at both sides
weigh the options
hopefully they're they're fair and
impartial and then they come up with a
you know a situation specific you know
judgment so i guess for the ai folks out
there i would i would say probably what
we should advocate for is some basic
sets of rules but at the end of the day
you need to have the capability for
human judgment you know to enter the
picture just to relate this to our
arguments again our core arguments
we're arguing that what you need is a
systems that can sort of come to
conventional agreements about
meanings and i would argue that a lot of
our legal systems democracy and juries
and so on are all about coming to
coming to agree on what is the right
thing in a particular situation that's a
very fundamentally important process in
our legal system and that's a process
we'd like our systems to be able to
engage with us in rather than just
having a hard decision this is fair this
is not fair
this is this is so interesting um
because if you think about it it's very
very complex again so we were talking
about the program of our culture being a
distributed it's it's a bit nebulous
it's amorphous it the boundary is very
vague and so on and you were just saying
that that we coalesce
and um if we're having a relativistic
discussion as well we we might say that
okay well we might think of um accepted
ways of doing things as being centroids
and we might think of how those how
those clusters of activity are related
to each other and we might because i
know you're interested in explanations
and using language we might come up with
abstract motifs to describe various
aspects of these systems but this is the
fundamental problem we have with ai and
as i said it could be very heterogeneous
but anyway i must i must get on to the
next point which is um and i'm sorry i'm
sorry to ask you this question but
everyone in in the audience wants to
know the answer to this uh we
interviewed yazaman rosseggi last week
and she did some really interesting
research
which showed a linear correlation
between the term frequency and the
training data set and the accuracy of
arithmetic operations on large language
models i'm not sure if you're familiar
with that work but um it seemed it at
least seemed to show that the models
were not really reasoning they were just
kind of memorizing the data set and we
already know that a lot of large
language models that their their
performance is largely dependent on the
the corpus and how the corpus is curated
and a lot of the large tech companies
not deepmind of course um are trying to
give the impression at least that these
models are doing reasoning which and by
reasoning we mean basically
extrapolating out of the training range
um what's your take on it so i think
it's great that people are doing
scientific work on this because i think
that
this is a very interesting
scientific
question
um
and
as a
cognitive psychologist the thing i want
to ask is well can we do some more
carefully controlled experiments with
the you know where we really lay out a
set of training data and we
see what that what sort of um
extrapolation that gives rise to or
non-extrapolation
i think that the
arithmetic results are very
interesting
i do have concerns about arithmetic
problems in particular with regards to
relatively low level issues like the
tokenizer because a lot of these models
don't
tokenize numbers in a way that would
make sense to us humans at all like it
might break a number like 184 up into
like 18 4 or something um or yeah anyway
so there's there's a lot of
weird issues
there that might give rise to very
that might make it very hard for the
system to learn about
arithmetic that i don't think are really
fundamentally about arithmetic or the
system's ability to do them but or
rather about the fact that these systems
were built for processing language their
tokenizers were designed to work well
for processing language and maybe if you
want them to do something like
arithmetic that's not the perfect way to
chop up their input right
um so i think that there are some
potential caveats there
i think that there's been a lot of
exploration of what these models can and
can't do that paints a sort of varied
picture so
to give you a couple of examples i mean
there's this um open source or a
collaborative data set called big bench
i'm not sure if you're familiar with it
but a group of researchers from google
brain
sourced about 200 tasks that were
explicitly sourced with the intention
that they would be hard for language
models so the big part of big bench
stands for beyond the imitation game
benchmark
so
if you look at these tasks they involve
all sorts of things like
reasoning about metaphors or doing
arithmetic reasoning or recognizing you
know things that are written out in
ascii art or something like that um so
there's a very wide range of stuff in
there that people thought would be hard
for language models
uh and i think that like
there's there's interesting patterns of
results on these tasks i mean some
things really do seem to be hard some
things seem easier than you think some
things are completely at chance even
with the best models
so i think there's
you know
those cases are potentially an
interesting
case to look at too when you're
considering this stuff the second thing
i want to bring up is there's this very
nice paper from my a year ago or so that
i think we referenced in the symbolic
behavior paper where someone
took a pre-trained language model and
taught it long division
with a few hundred examples um but gave
it very detailed
traces of what those problems should how
to how to do the long division process
and allowed it to write on a an external
scratch pad so it was able to sort of
like write down a token and then look
back at that token later like a kid
might do if they were doing a long
dividend problem and
that system was able to
generalize to other long division
problems quite well as i understand it
i think that's
an interesting slightly different case
study right it's like well okay
so a model with a weird tokenizer
trained on language modeling doesn't do
arithmetic reasoning perfectly but how
do humans learn how to do arithmetic
someone actually sits down and teaches
them and walks them through the steps
right and maybe they need to write
things down on paper while they're
learning how to do it and maybe they
learn with some sort of external aids to
understand counting and so on they they
learn about counting before they learn
about arithmetic so i think there's
a
wide
constellation of things that are
relevant to human reasoning things like
the external aids we have like things
that we can write on
things like the educational process we
have that teaches us certain patterns of
reasoning
i wouldn't
i'm not surprised when
a model that's trained on next token
prediction doesn't do all these aspects
of reasoning perfectly and i'm kind of
surprised when people
are surprised by that right but that
doesn't necessarily mean there's
anything wrong with let's say the class
of transformers as models per se
it might just mean well there's some
aspects of what it takes to get
intelligence that are not
covered
yet by the things we've been training
them on
yeah i have to i have to challenge on
one thing here which is the point of
yasmin's paper wasn't that uh you know
these models weren't doing arithmetic
perfectly it was that they were failing
in a very particular way that was highly
correlated
you know with the corpus when you're
trying to judge intelligence it's just
it's even more important actually to
look at the ways in which an agent fails
than the ways in which it it succeeds
totally i absolutely agree with that
just to get back to the correlated with
the corpus thing though that's also part
of how the tokenization gets constructed
right is what is the occurrence
frequency of these particular pieces of
the text corpus right and so you could
interpret that correlation in different
ways and i i so i haven't read this
paper
it's on my reading this but i haven't
gotten to it yet but i'm interested to
see if they looked at things like well
is it correlated with which particular
tokens are you know
is that correlation mediated by the
tokenization for instance um i do think
that you will see
frequency biases in these models though
certainly trained on um
on next word prediction but even in
general but to bring it back to the
human case again we also see that humans
are very
content biased reasoners so i mentioned
this task called the waste on selection
task earlier which is a sort of logical
inference task where basically the goal
is you tell a a participant a rule like
here's a set of some cards if a card has
an even number on the front that should
have a vowel on the other side and then
you show the two cards that have the
numbers one and
one card with the number one one card
with the number two a card with a letter
a and a card with the letter b and you
ask them which cards do you have to flip
over to check if the rule is being
followed
and
people are not particularly good at this
they mix up the converse and the
contrapositive and so they're not good
at getting the well if it's an even
number then it should have a vowel on
the other side therefore
to check whether it has
whether this rule is being violated we
need to flip over the one that doesn't
have a vowel because that's what would
make that rule not that proposition not
true right the interesting finding is
that you can take this same
logical situation and you can put it
into a much more familiar situation for
people by saying well these cards have
people's ages and what they're drinking
and
if the the number on them is yeah so if
the age if they're drinking alcohol then
the number must be over 21 right the age
must be over 21. and then people are
basically perfect at solving this task
right so i think that people's reasoning
is also biased by how familiar the
particular things we're reasoning about
are
and that may be one of the
you know again that may be a feature as
well as a bug because it allows us to do
well
in the situations that are most common
so i think that humans can
escape some of these biases but again i
think that's something that we have to
do through education through being
trained to reason more logically to use
these rules in a systematic way i think
that's something that we can also train
our models to do
under appropriate circumstances but i'm
not sure that next token prediction is
the perfect circumstance for that
indeed um
very quick final question if if i
trained an andrew robot let's imagine i
i had the simulator of the world and um
by the way that reminded me i was going
to ask you an interesting question
earlier you know in the matrix the um
the architect the first version of the
matrix was a perfect simulation wasn't
it and no there were no bad people in it
but um anyway um i i'm having a chat
with the architect i've done a whole
bunch of simulations i've got an andrew
robot and and andrew now can respond to
any situation you're likely to face you
know for the next five days and i
compress all of that hash table into
something called a neural network and no
one has any idea that it's not the real
andrew that they just you know they
can't distinguish would you think that
that andrew was intelligent i think
that's an
yeah that's a great
question um
i don't think that it
has to be intelligent like i do
yeah i i do feel like a perfect look up
table is not
intelligent i feel like intelligence is
about adapting to new situations
definitely um
so
no i wouldn't
say that that system is intelligent
necessarily and
and uh let's suppose
let's suppose it's not intelligent let's
suppose it was intelligent maybe we
modified it a bit so you decided it was
intelligent would it be conscious oh i
don't i don't i don't talk about
consciousness i don't want to get into
that
i i don't think we have a good
definition it's all about that little
bit extra
yes indeed
um well andrew uh dr lampton i should
say from deepmind it's been an absolute
honour thank you so much for joining us
for having me it was a lot of fun
remember to like comment and subscribe
and we will see you back next week